but what we have in westeros of course
living or patrolling the wall
is the night's watch it's a place where
all the brothers
are equal where your past doesn't matter
uh
where you can get on in life and uh by
the power of your sword
well lord snow it appears you're the
least useless person here
i think there's certainly an element of
that in some of the warrior
monks of the middle ages hear my words
and bear witness to my vow
night gathers and now my watch begins
a lot of the stuff about the night's
watch comes from the church militant of
the crusades the templars and the
hospitals
they were sworn to poverty and obedience
they were
sworn to chastity i shall take no wife
yes that's in there's no denying that i
shall
father know children's very specific but
what our vows have to say about other
activities he's open to interpretation
but they were also warriors
and there were several different orders
though the one that lasted the longest
was a knights hospital
who initially began in the hospital in
jerusalem
their great rival was the templars who
were even more powerful
knights templar what do we know the
knights templar well they were sworn to
protect jerusalem
did not have an ice wall around it but
nevertheless they had this
duty to defend the christian lands in
the middle east
so there's you know huge history of
these military
orders of essentially fighting monks
last time i saw rob he was in the
courtyard of winterfell he was better
than me at everything
i wanted to hate him but i never could
jon snow i think is everyone's favorite
hero of game of thrones
and we really root for him because of
his status in life he's a bastard
a bastard boy with nothing to inherit
off to join the
ancient order of the night's watch in
westeros jon snow
finds his way in the world by becoming a
soldier by becoming a
nightly character lord snow here grew up
in a castle
spitting down on the likes of you do you
think ned starks
bastard bleeds like the rest of us noble
and royal bastards
would be in similar situations in the
middle ages
they were quite aware that they weren't
at the same level or have the same
status within the family
as their brothers and sisters the draw
for
a bastard like jon snow of of going
north to the wall
and joining the knights watch is that
it's an opportunity for him to make a
career for himself
welcome 1000 foot of ice wall now that's
a creative genius we don't know of any
ice walls like that
but we do have hadrian's wall hadrian
walls 70 plus miles
and the romans did it why because they
didn't really want the scots down within
the wall was a defensive measure it was
hadrian
drawing the boundaries of of the empire
and saying
on this side civilization on that side
wilderness madness savagery
and we want to keep it there i'm sure
the scots
today would be very offended to be
compared to wildlings but in the middle
ages that was exactly how they were seen
certainly in england when i came to
wright ice and fire i knew i wanted to
have a wall
but of course you know in my philosophy
of turning it up to 11 i actually turned
it up to i think at least 37
in this case because i made my wall
700 feet high and made of ice
and magic keeping out unimaginable
evils beyond instead of just scotsman